[Music]
what if I told you that arguably the
best rainbow six each player in the
world was banned for a climb he may not
have committed imagine simple in csgo
that's called cheating kiss Pam for two
years that for the better part of two
years
Stefan shy Cola Blue has been subjected
to a never-ending sea of shame I'm
telling you he's cheating it psycho he
was hated yeah I'm playing psych oh my
god the biggest shooter in the game he
was humiliated because you got fans a
the power all because of one fateful
encounter with Penghu the man who in the
public's eyes is considered to be the
greatest player of all time to this day
it isn't actually clear whether psycho
cheated or not but what we do know is
that he's back and he's nuttier than
ever he is fighting everything there is
no fear in this all by what a legend
psycho you can't
before we get into all of that I just
want to tell you guys to make sure to
tune in to movie stops 2019 Rainbow six
siege US Nationals the finals are coming
up in December and trust me you do not
want to miss it
for more about u.s. nationals and all
kinds of six each action check out the
links in our description below despite
all of his claims to innocence psycho is
the most high-profile siege player to
ever be found guilty of cheating because
of that he's had to watch his name get
dragged through the mud by one of the
most decorated players in the game like
there's a reason why he got been for
Cody alright who is sheikha and how did
he become the most scandalous player in
C let's go back to 2017 when this 18
year old French pub star was conning the
ranks of Challenger League with an
up-and-coming roster known as Bee Gees
but I don't such a cool little bi cohosh
bit everybody watch watch I'm such a
[ __ ]
from the very beginning it was clear
that Chico was a mechanical gone he may
have been quiet and brooding in person
but once he loaded onto the server
he was explosive the guy was like Bobo
on steroids
the way he pushes for himself
can be his body can be his crosshair
really he he set up himself to have like
always the advantage on the on the fact
that he's gonna take but the thing that
really stood out about psycho was his
back when competitive siege was still
young and the skill ceiling seemed miles
away people thought that psycho had hit
it he just had this ability to dish out
incredible plays so incredible that some
people got suspicious by late 2017
psycho made his professional debut where
Chuck who's gonna drop from attic into
the meeting hall well Ivan knows he's
there goes for a pre fire and boom it
goes and within two months he
established himself as one of the
greatest mechanical talents in prolene
my question is where his shy cope in for
the past year and a half of where has he
been
where has he been hiding this talent
that's what I want to know but during a
match against Penta the best team in the
world
someone finally got suspicious enough of
psychos seemingly impossible rise to the
top to report him and that person was
Penta superstar Penghu lot of rumors
going on that there was some suspicious
stuff going on and no one could really
point to what it was this story was that
he had more information than you humanly
possibly could so that would refer to a
weaker wall hacks or some sort of way to
gain information that you shouldn't
otherwise have that there's a normal
human being and the first mode of
contact a great shot psycho what an
unbelievable kill on Judas there we beat
them in a very very very close game and
we protested because we had to space you
know something goes wrong here and there
there's Shaco he's gonna snag the downed
frag onto Fabien who's on for burst tags
another under KS and then gets removed
we then came together the entire public
scene and we spoke to the developer of
mas which is the anti-cheating program
that we use in pro league and we found
this like macro sequence code at the
bottom and we send all that information
to yourself on October 11th ESL
announced that psycho was a band well
they couldn't find any evidence of
wallhacks
pain manipulation or the use of
P n there anything chief software moss
had detected what they interpreted to be
a macro specifically a series of
instances where Michael was spamming his
four key and an allegedly inhuman speed
and just like that without any notice or
even a chance to respond psycho and his
entire team were disqualified from
prolene on top of that psycho got
slapped with a two-year ban all for a
crime he swore he didn't command is
joking via - that is crazy
Sandford Bashir is a walking path in the
community was used to conceal a comma
and she'd of capitalism she massaged
will prove a Republican on Sunday learn
leadership a sheet of edge to Solomon
never kill bunch to Solomon me for been
evolved it's over I wrecked him he cry
immediately be genius mounted their
defense they compiled a nineteen page
report of all the pro players whose mas
files were similar to Jenkins
I don't think it was really America I
think he'd just like it sort of ditch or
just landed I appears when the keyboard
accounts registered the keeping pressed
as fast as he did next they released
what they claimed was a video proof that
psychos four key was assigned to his
primary gadget not recoil control as
many people in the community had
speculated what I personally believe is
that he was just first a lot of times
and at the time that the keyboard or the
computer registers through it he
couldn't like it was a bit too fast
you press it very hard especially on for
when his thing was even out it's
happening because the he has to to
activate the ex Kairos so he is like
pushing for for for foreign and smash
it's so it's actually his teammates even
released an hour-long YouTube video
demonstrating how unreliable mas can be
but it didn't matter
ESL never even responded to be geniuses
claims it's be honest it was kind of
poorly handled it's like it wasn't a
sure thing doesn't like your very
mastered vague controls news of psychos
bands spread through the siege community
like wildfire on one hand there were
people who were celebrating that justice
was being served on the other hand some
people were in disbelief or even
wait a lot of this had to do with the
fact that psychos biggest attractor was
Penghu one of the biggest siege players
in the world where I get all these infos
I found it I am the person that got shy
of event approaches it him
that's me it didn't take long for the
community to start memeing at psychos
expense either slowly but surely he went
from the most talented player to ever
touch the game to a pariah yeah I'm
playing psycho my guy the biggest
shooter in the game but despite all the
ridicule psycho stuck with siege he
never switched to another game that he
could have played professionally instead
he just spent all this time trying to
become a better fragment if you if you
cheated like if there was some like a
cheater would get bad like he would say
for kids I'm gonna just go to another
game or to something else if he was not
[ __ ] if he indeed like Kali he wants
to do is to say maybe okay I have real
literature here and I just want to do my
best to come back as soon as possible
instantly when he knew that he had like
a chance to compete again in Rainbow six
he stayed there and keep grinding the
game and it also became clear that his
talents weren't limited see it didn't
take long for people to start wondering
if maybe psychos ban was BS maybe lost
made a mistake and sheikha was just too
good at siege at a time when people
weren't ready for me I never really
looked into it never like looked at like
I know a lot of people look to this like
moss like it's like this green capture
like is keylogger fans for anti-cheat
but um I don't know it's it's very I've
heard from like credible sources that he
did and then you never really know in
April 20 19 something unexpected
happened
Sycho ban was lifted early thanks to
some sort of ESL orchestrated rehab he
was immediately signed by BDS eSport and
after qualifying for European Challenger
League began preparations for Dreamhack
Montreal his first glance is the game
that got him banned now many people
expected psycho to go ham given that he
had something of a bone to pick what
they didn't expect though was one of the
most dominant performances in the
history of the game here in this
and as fate would have it BDS was
matched up against g2 which meant that
psychos next opponent
was the man who got him banned the man
who'd won three world titles since that
ban Shenko was out for blood a little
bit more damage and chooses to play a
little bit more save three fires once
again and Schuykill finds him through
the wall to the hole that was made
psycho is literally like the John wick
of siege man psycho finds another beep
nuts smoked dead dota is all alone here
one versus four not even gonna find the
first one
Shaco closes without shakers in a great
spot to find another baby as well a
triple for Keiko this is it unreal
performance it's two versus the world
they don't have an inch in this world
Drago finds out sports he's looking for
the ace BDS is just powered up with our
maximum power flawless
BDS went on to finish third at Dreamhack
but in the months since the hype around
psycho has escalated into a full-blown
fever
he dropped 25 kills in one game against
luminosity one map against luminosity
that they lost that map by the way he
was by far the most dominant player of
the entire tournament and yeah I mean
how is that for revenge how is that for
a story I mean it was just it was so
fascinating to watch it really was we
may never know for sure exactly what
happened and that match with Penta but
what we do know is that right now psycho
is one of the greatest players to ever
touch siege I don't think anybody can
deny that he is just like mechanically
gifted like he's got he's got crazy
movement crazy aim and he's a good
player like regardless of his past you
know anything that's happened if it did
or did not
you really can't deny that he is just a
I guess you want to say beast the
question is will we ever be able to
remove the stigma around his name
there's not a bad player whatsoever like
you look at him now even after all this
stuff has happened and he is by far a
really really really good player and
that's why I like people are sad about
it because it was wasted talent because
he probably would be out there in top
five in the world probably but given
that he's proven himself on a land
people are warming up to the idea that
psycho might be the real deal after all
can be the best be a new wolf we do it's
not like everybody's calling cheating I
think for the most part he's kind of
it's like it's like 50/50 basically if
you ask one person yeah he's a cheater
if yes other person he's a beast so I
think I think he's in a good decent spot
considering the past and after all that
psycho and medius qualified for pro
league season 11 BDS go into pro league
that means that he and Penge will face
off again and again getting a chance for
revenge and to prove his innocence
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages